judging by the grandness and length of
this wall you could be forgiven for
thinking that it's in China but this is
the Great Wall of India become bell
gutter wall is located in Moraga Stan
roughly a 10 hour drive from New Delhi
its remoteness has caused this stunning
location to be relatively unknown even
to locals the wall is made of thousands
of stone bricks with artistic flourishes
on top it has seven gateways and took
over a century to construct it was a
place of refuge in times of danger the
wall snakes through valleys and along
mountaintops after the Great Wall of
China it is the second longest
continuous wall in the world it is 22
miles in length and surrounds the fort
of over 300 Asian temples that were
believed to have been built in the 15th
century in 2013 it was declared a UNESCO
World Heritage Site a majority of the
wall sits high serving as a lookout and
giving incredible views of the
surrounding mountains and farmlands
unlike anywhere else in India